hello hello hello we haven't done one of
these in a while
just fixing up ui bugs you know
not ui bugs but ui
uh the ui
what is your driving sketching on my
board
now i'm happy to talk about all that um
yeah
made the ui 10x faster
hello hello we're really here to talk
today about hiring
but we're going to throw in a few zeuxes
i know you guys want to want to talk
about that i know that's what people are
interested in
i'm just going to go through we're going
to go to twitter
and we're going to see what people are
saying
burton county welcome uh the mahindra s
uh will be supported as soon as somebody
wants to pay us 250 grand
to port it or somebody else look we're
not going to trash talk zooks i mean
look if you're an investor in zoox
you got your money back if you're
a founder of zulks you negotiated a
payday for yourself
if you're an employee of zoox ah you
didn't get [ __ ] but ah who cares about
the employees anyway right
not um we'll see we'll see what happens
uh i don't know why amazon bought them
for
that much i think
damn you know bezos wants uh
rocket company you got your self-driving
company
you know and put it this way if you're
going to the space station do you want
to ride on a spacex
or a blue origin i don't know um not to
hate on bezos look you know except for
the 40 billion he lost in the divorce
he's great
uh but let's see let's just see what the
twitter is saying about zooks and we can
we can go through it and i know i know
that's what you guys want to talk about
so
amazon acquires self-driving startup
dukes for over
1.2 billion so they raised 990 million
so it is a little bit more
uh than they raised
uh but my understanding is some of the
later investors had multiples on their
investment
which means they're guaranteed a payout
um you know if we go back to
tacoma ai's medium and you guys can see
uh
this is this is what i said in in
october
um so you know it's not it's not quite
as bad as uh
we will have it the easiest when they're
shut down the employees there will be
reabsorbent to google
crews will be in the middle when they're
shut down the employees there will
attempt to be absorbed into gm and
zuke's let's just say i'm glad i don't
work there right
if you're a zuk's employee you're now an
amazon employee
working at amazon
uh all right all right all right so
3.6
oh my god the car manufacturer is
locking me out
uh the car manufacturer is locking me
out
look do i even have to talk about this
again can you guys in the comments say
what i'm gonna say
to that person who always asked this
question oh no
oh no toyota's gonna lock me out honda's
gonna lock me out
um thug means never having to say you're
sorry
yeah all right um so yeah i mean
you're you're you're now a you know an
amazon employee you know what not as bad
not as bad as drive that ai
but uh
i mean it really comes down to
no i wasn't pissed when i saw zooks get
it quiet why would i be pissed about
that
it's not it's not that surprising right
and i've always said it's not that zooks
has nothing
it's that the whole idea doesn't make
sense
our argo i think has nothing um no i you
know and i gave i gave zooks props for
those videos
uh when they came out you know they
started to explain it like like
engineers
um is zuk's worth a billion dollars well
they put 990 million into it so
a 1x return a one extra time so when you
look at a vc
return uh multiple
pi chart it's like a classic one here
uh no no no no no
um 1x 2x less than 1x let's see if i can
find it
i don't know how to find it
vc return mostly though we're here to
talk about
uh
hiring for common ai
bc return i don't know
you know what to be honest hating on
hating on the
good good for zooks i hope everyone
there got got the outcome they wanted i
mean
if i woke up and i was an amazon
employee tomorrow
you know there's worse things there's
definitely worse things
um percent of investments by vc return
there's like a chart
percentage of investment by
dc return
i saw a really good pie chart that
explained it we just got it we just got
here we got perfect
vc fund return on investment all right
so 50 of the companies return less than
one x drive that ai is here
zuke's is here um
and then these five percent of the
companies that that the vcs are
uh super happy they invest in these
these are the these are the big name
tech companies and these are really how
vcs make all of their
uh money
so yeah
1.2 billion
well let's see maybe we can find stuff
about that deal so it's
possible that like suzuka's raised
basically they raised
uh 790 million in their earlier rounds
they were trying to raise a 700 million
dollar round they only raised
200 of those 700 million in convertible
notes
um so let's see if we can find something
i think oh there was a word
uh
nah there's nothing if i search for
zuk's vc multiple um
hmm
9.55
ah ratchet
yeah due to ratchets on later rounds
i've never heard this before
but
the company raised 1 billion in equity
in convertible debt investors are
basically going to make their money back
and some will make a positive return
while the pre-money valuation was
2.7 billion in 2008 those investors
no i mean look it's a it's a large
acquisition
right um do i personally care uh about
dukes
you know they've just been with the
story for a long time so it's nice to
see
uh the story arc of zooks is as a story
arc
um that we've been following
so it's good to bring nice closure to
everybody uh what's our plan for qt with
ui so i just i just made this nice
change to ui
uh which helps improve the interaction
between ui.c and model.c
but mostly what we're here to talk about
today is hiring for chrome ai
unless are there any last luke's
questions you could see there was some
interesting um
when you searched common ai on twitter i
searched this this morning and i saw
some interesting stuff
uh yeah you know
myth tesla leads to autonomy right like
some totally fake [ __ ]
uh yeah why isn't common ai on there do
you wonder would have expected this to
become
ai um
coming i could do most of a tesla system
could do on a smartphone or two cameras
zoox's team was highly regarded that's
questionable what do i think of this
deal
how about this the real thing to think
about this deal is bezos
lost 40 billion in a divorce
no concern for comma um
the concern for comma here's here's what
i would be concerned if i was comma
if tomorrow the auto oems fired all
their ceos
and put in software people that would be
like oh well
combo was good while it lasted the good
news is that's never going to happen
um actually another another bit of news
which is kind of interesting so if you
guys
heard me rip on nvidia um
in the uh in the third or tesla podcast
um
so this this story came out
mercedes-benz and nvidia partnered to
bring
software-defined vehicles to market in
2024.
so nvidia's chips are extremely
overpriced
um they're trying to get like 500 uh to
put their stuff in the car
mobilize about fifty dollars comma um in
huge quantities is about fifty dollars
as well
uh nvidia is 500. so what cars can
support
actual 500 cost for an add-on well the
mercedes s-class right and that's the
car that it's going to come to in 2024.
now that said rimac yeah rimac is also
how much is a rim that car
does rimac actually sell cars it's it's
hard to keep in my head
which one of these are scams and which
one of them are not scams
um does rim xl design
innovation oh they yeah they're hyper
car
um do they how many cars have they sold
ah it's like that like rimac
lucid faraday future rivien uh
some of them are scams some of them are
good uh what's that other one that has
like five cars in their lineup but
hasn't actually shipped any cars yet um
i rode in the faraday future it wasn't
that much of a scam and
they had one car they showed it to me i
sat in it we did a launch
uh hardware seemed pretty nice the
software
and i saw it there's a little thing uh
on the window it's like a windows little
lcd screen
nickel and nickel is the one that like
oh we announced five cars but um
uh are you planning on expanding my
product fleet why don't you buy a comma
two bro
um yeah the new medium posts are coming
from our head of research
our head of open pilot and uh
our new cll
yeah yeah i saw the gta okay um
where else what else did i want to talk
about i said i wanted to talk about
something else oh this is kind of
interesting too
today my software update the model 3
also asked to start recording on the
interior camera
um all right all right tesla we'll see
we'll see when you're
i've always bet the tesla's gonna come
out with driver monitoring before they
have fsd
and we'll see if that is uh true or not
but if anyone would like to bet me ten
thousand dollars on that
uh i'm down to take that back um before
tesla has fsd
where they say you cannot pay attention
during your commute
um tesla will add camera based
driver monitoring anyone like to bet 10
grand on that i'm down to about 10 grand
oh yeah this
so um i'm going to call right now that
there's a 50
chance that this car ends up running
open pilot
now you say george um how is this car
going to end up running open pilot
have you been in talks with mercedes and
nvidia and the answer to that is of
course not
but what's going to happen as they
approach this date the software is not
going to be done
it's not going to have millions of miles
of of real road testing
mercedes is going to take it out they're
going to complain to nvidia about
you know all the neural nets the neural
nets you know
um so what's going to end up happening
is they're not really going to have a
choice
they're going to have someone in the
team 20 20
probably even 2022 is going to have
is going to have a comma device in their
car and they're gonna be like you know
this codes open source and we can
probably get it to run
um and they will and the rest will be
history so that's i give it a 50
chance that this mercedes actually ends
up running uh running open pilot
um europe is important tell me more
about this
um common needs europe to succeed
tell me what do you mean what do i not
do for europe
i don't need [ __ ] right what do i need
to
succeed software engineers that's what i
need uh do we hire people from yeah
absolutely um if
we can the visa situation is a little uh
difficult right now
but um yeah we have a whole bunch of
people uh from europe
who came here now i mean that's a
separate thing right do we hire european
software engineers absolutely absolutely
brilliant software engineers in europe
do i somehow need to
go to the european market in order to
succeed no
i have more data than i know what to do
with right now all we need right now
is software engineers and that brings me
to the main point
of this post we're getting very serious
about hiring you know
we're happy to sponsor h1b once h1bs are
back to normal
h1b j1 and 01 if you
i mean we've sponsored all ones before
as well i'm happy to give you a
sponsorship
um hold also if you're in europe and
you're interested in working for comma
we have an interesting announcement
coming uh in a bit
but
so the unconjoined triangle of success
at comma our mission is to solve
self-driving cars while delivering
shippable intermediaries
everything we do is derived from that
mission and as the narrative unfolds it
looks increasingly like we will win
alongside tesla and mobileye um so
like just talk about how different that
is from
from uh another company's post
uh what guarantee does someone have if
they move across the country or
world that you won't fire them for no
reason no one gets fired for no reason
if you're adding if you're brilliant and
adding tons of value to comma why would
i fire you
that makes no sense if you're slacking
and causing trouble and requiring
a lot of uh management then yeah of
course i'll fire you um
so what guarantee you have no guarantee
and if you're the kind of person who
needs guarantees
i don't think kama's for you if you're
the kind of person who's willing to
kama should never fire people
no it's terrible but you know you got to
do it right because otherwise you'll end
up like google with a whole lot of bad
people or all the good people left right
um yeah no i i look one of the biggest
things for me
if i'm thinking about uh how to
uh
you know if i'm thinking about a company
i want to work for i want to work for a
company full of
great people right well you know
you can do a lot in the pre-screen but
you got to make sure the bar stays
really high not just for who you hire
but also we keep around
um
uh i really don't recommend starting a
company
uh oh you're the guy who borrowed the uh
for the volt from
it's coming pretty well it's going
pretty well if you'll see actually on
your on your
obd2 harness uh there was a little
mistake in how the voltage regulator was
put on so there's a bunch of body wires
and glue
that's going to be fixed in all the
production ones comma shouldn't fire
people and should give their product
away for free
yes absolutely absolutely power to the
people workers of the world unite
all right um back in reality uh
so we have three teams we have the open
pilot team the research team and the
operations team
the open pilot team builds and maintains
the open powered software
the research team builds the models the
operations team makes
the product the money the website and
the app
um so we can go through a few of the
jobs we're hiring for
you do not need to know anything in
particular
uh about self-driving cars in order to
work here
um so if you think oh i don't know about
self-driving cars how could i work here
that doesn't matter we don't care uh
basically
the two things we really look for are be
smart and be motivated
also know how to program be smart be
motivated and know how to program
um competitors if you've done
competitions math competitions
science fairs competitive programming
ctfs
uh we're interested that's a great thing
to to have on your resume
um
contribute to open source projects have
a great github
um easy
if you don't you know you should have a
github with with stars on it and github
that shows that
you can you write a lot of code right
how do you get good at writing code you
write a lot of code
um and then people who are people who
are good at like thinking things through
and don't just you know type lots of
code um
all our positions are full-time and
on-site in downtown san diego
uh though if you're in europe
uh there'll be there'll be uh an
announcement coming
um you know to deal with that to do the
visa situation
comet has full free lunch we have a we
have a chef who comes in and cooks a hot
lunch for everybody
uh every lunch uh we do
uh if you're in the office feel free to
order ubereats we go to dinner almost
every day
so we're looking for senior software
engineers software engineers
uh to join the open pilot team
um we're looking for
ml engineers and data scientists uh
we're looking for a safety engineer
uh this is somebody who's going to think
about safety some people think they can
apply for this and not be able to code
no no no you absolutely have to be able
to code um
you know someone's got to write like the
code to do when we do comma aeb and
stuff
um infrastructure engineer tons of tools
need building uh self-driving is largely
an infrastructure problem
ml is largely an infrastructure problem
uh
so yeah i mean you know being able to
deal with big data being able to
dispatch things to a thousand machines
uh all that stuff a thousand coins we
don't have a thousand machines
uh full stack engineer we're very
excited about hiring this
uh we got to get somebody in to make the
app good
to make the api good uh prime is
starting to become a real
uh profit center for the company well
not quite yet actually prime
costs a ton of money but soon
prime will make money and we want to
make great quality experience
for our users we don't use kubernetes we
use docker for a bunch of things
kubernetes confusing um navigation
designer
so yes uh we will eventually be adding
navigation
into open pilot open pilot needs to know
where you are going
there's a lot a lot of trolls in the
comments today man you know
from what i heard um oh operations
assistant oh it's been changed
uh yeah we didn't talk about that one
um that one is uh
this is really what we're looking to get
really really um
uh look guys
this year we've sold a lot more stuff
we started selling at a 3x increase in
revenue
um this year versus the same time last
year
uh i'd rather work at a big company
where i don't need high motivation
it's great it's great people uh
select themselves out but no i mean it's
a problem and you know i'm judging it a
bit from you guys in the comments too
it's like
we're getting a lot um
we're getting a lot more regions but
they're just not from people who are
good
not from people who would hire uh yeah
the bar is like really high to solve
these problems
look self-driving is going to be solved
by 20 geniuses right it's not going to
be solved by a thousand people
it just i don't think any research
problems in history have ever been
solved that way
right you have some like you know on the
extreme end you have things like the
proof of formats last theorem
right which is solved really by it's one
lone genius it's one lone genius
building on top of a lot of other
people's work and of course you're
always going to be building on top of
other people's work that's how any
science or research or engineering works
but
you know in reality there's nothing
self-driving is going to be solved by 20
people
and uh you know a thousand computers
right if you believe in like an ml
solution to self-driving there's not
going to be
a lot of open pilot in and of itself
except for adding navigation to it like
the the whole ux
and stuff is kind of done like it can
use some refinement and stuff
but like it's it's there we have um some
good stuff as we approach won't point
out
um
i'm brutally on you have to be brutally
honest look if you want to get anything
done in the world and you're being
dishonest you're only hurting yourself
[Music]
so yeah i mean it's really the two
things that we look for
fundamentally are intelligence and
motivation
um and then both of those things
generally over time i mean there's some
amount of there's some amount of uh
skill required like if you can't program
i wonder why you can't program
um
we don't hire remote employees uh
though like i said if you're in europe
and you're looking
uh announcement announcement coming
um i don't know i'm not sure this this
uh judging from the comments here i'm
really not sure that this uh
yeah i'm gonna think about it
i'm gonna have to think about like how
where
yeah the regions have been getting worse
right i was hoping as we grew i was
hoping as we grew and we got more
users and we do we have a lot more
attention now our google trends are up
but the quality of the candidates have
has fallen
uh so yeah i don't know i don't really
know what to do about this
um i think maybe one of the things we
can do is start writing up a lot of
technical
see i mean i don't know personally i
think a lot of education is just a
straight up scam
like what should you study to prepare i
almost don't
care like you should program and you
should practice programming
but it's not like it's studying right
it's like it's practicing way more than
studying
i don't care if you memorized a book who
cares that's what i think of when i
think of studying
now have you put 10 000 hours into
programming that's that makes you good
um yeah i think i think maybe that's
something we can do we can start we can
start documenting
um our code better how a lot of the
stack works better
writing like high quality but somewhat
dry technical documentation
i think i think might help
i mean by create an open source
community i'm going to slap a foundation
label on it and incorporate it as a
non-profit what do you think that
changes man
you know this is this is the uh it's the
cargo cult of business
when people think it's it's things like
that um
when will comma go public never uh
the more i've the more i've looked into
that
bearish on that uh
so look the comma two sold 3x more than
the yield
if the products keep increasing in the
way they've been increasing
the thing about exponential is it gets
it gets real big real
fast so if this stuff works i'm thinking
in a few years even with our current
or consumer electronics company uh
we're gonna have really large cash flows
and we've defined a new sector
right the the self-driving add-on thing
in sre can i apply when you need my
permission apply
we'll do it we do a phone screen and we
do a program challenge you do well on
those look
it's a real uh it's all merit-based man
i don't care what your title is i don't
really care that much what's on your
resume
um shirts are out of stock
uh what's our current burn rate negative
bro it's negative because we make money
because we're a profitable company
no i hate remote remotes terrible
uh the only way to possibly get
considered for remote
is if you've contributed tons of pull
requests to openpilot
uh and then we can consider uh bringing
you on but there is no way
we will hire someone new for a remote
position um these people are too hard to
manage honestly i think a lot of people
who ask for a mode is because they want
to slack off
um ah you thought the purpose of a
startup was to burn vc as quickly as
possible that's the old
it's a new decade it's 2020. everything
changed
do i do work experience
again how's your github look right you
want work experience
show me like two open source projects
you made that are in use wow
damn that's good that's good work
experience
um
did our investors make money already no
i'll give them their money they want
their money back i'll get my money back
i'll give them just like zooks you know
come back
um how can comma
two beat all these
why do you think they're my competition
why do you think they are a competition
uh why do you think why do you think we
compete
with amazon and google we don't
um
i can't get a job in programming because
i can't sell
myself can you help
ah yeah i've tried to be nicer in the
interviews i've tried to be nicer
oh yes going joe rogan oh that's going
to get me a whole a whole lot of inbound
that i want
um
[Music]
but uh you know
i want more technical stuff we'll show
more technical content this is what i've
been working on this week
thinking in vision features right when
you think in your brain about driving
uh you don't think about um you don't
think of pictures
you think features so we have our great
vision model a bunch of convies
then we're building these models auto
encoder decoder you can you can
visualize it oh we gotta put that we
gotta put that on twitter that looks
cool
um augmentation model dynamics model
uh hardware people i mean maybe
uh our new again if you do hardware and
you can also code
yeah we're interested if you just do
hardware and can't code
i don't think so um
let's see oh yeah and this is kind of
cool to show you guys
uh so this is one of the things i've
been working on
so what this is here this is the
how this is the box uh that open pilot
is using in order to drive
and this is a visualization model from
the vision features so i trained an auto
encoder
to take the vision features and bring
them back up uh to an image
this is what it looks like when it's a
video you see how that thing appeared
there
look at the lane change so this is how
open pilot's actually seeing the world
i'm going to start doing a lot more
stuff where we think in these vision
features
right
you're going to see something
interesting up here when a car comes
across
yeah i know the auto encoder doesn't
perfectly capture it you know the loss
function is not perfect
it's not sampled it's averaged
um yeah well
you know it's decent here
part of the problem also is this a small
model a new big model
i'll show you guys another one
that's another one
it's not a vae it's not variational i'm
not doing any sort of bit restriction on
it we're training the vision model
separately
supervised um and then we just take the
features and bring them back
uh to the image space
i'll show you guys another thing
um ah what's holding back zero eight
uh a lot of work yeah a lot
but a lot of hard work uh we're making
some big changes to the models
we're getting the models ready for level
5.
so you can give this a second to load
here
how's the simulator coming along this is
the simulator in
vision feature space
yeah i'm reading the comments
uh yeah we use the finite state machine
for lane change i'm not really sure how
else you do it
so we can actually move so like i can
here this is it's wasde so you move
around with wasd just like a video game
so i can like turn i can also strafe
and this is thinking in vision feature
space
i'm just using a transformation model
inside of the space that
open pilot's using to reason
yeah i can also i can also was do with a
uh
so if i don't use the ml transform model
right whoops
sheep onto
so give this one a second to load this
one's actually using uh the image and
just doing uh
normal augmentation
i can't drive oh my god it turns so
slowly
uh yeah but we don't actually go back to
the rgb image when we do any of the
training
um yeah we are we had a big uh we had an
off site
last week we our level five summit
where we discussed very seriously what
it's going to take to get
the well we settled on level three
um there's some chance
we we think tesla's going to be first to
level three
uh with us in seconds we think there's
some chance we'll beat them
um
yeah we can augment in the light in
space basically
this looks like something i mean it's
the wrong thing but it was something
it's better than cruise i think uh
i've said that way before their
acquisition too i think the the bigger
problem
is and that now now zooks and crews look
similar so what are the outcomes for
zuk's employees they're gonna look
similar to amazon employees
um
lsd slam uses photometric losses the
comma 2 is not that good at photometric
loss
very good geometric loss um but yeah
everything we're doing is geometric not
photometric
oh my god the more camera question no
no i never plan to add another camera
never
never we're always going to be on one
camera i'm getting paid by big one
camera to make sure we only ever stay on
one camera
uh i think we're doing ces in 2021 yeah
you want to order a comma two so bad
what are you currently doing to address
what am i doing
uh the thermal issues are gonna get
better yeah they're gonna get better
uh we've there's there's a few problems
with it we're doing a bunch of tests
now if i go to zero cameras big one
camera won't pay me
i've only added three cameras all
pointing the same direction with similar
fields of views is that what you guys
want will that make you all happy
uh when will shirts be in stock again
bro i don't know
i think i know that i think shirts
didn't make us enough money
i think shirts weren't a big profit
center for the company we need profit
centers i love
profit
why are we so open because no one
listens to us anyway you know
that's going to be the real joke and
that's going to be the real joke when
all this stuff is over
you could be open you can say the truth
people don't listen
they hear what they want to hear they're
in their echo chambers
uh you know a lot of them have uh
when you're invested when you've put con
has been around for five years right if
you're at waymo and you've put 10 15
years of your life into this and you're
like
are you gonna be like you're gonna wake
up one day and be like you know guys i
don't actually think this is the right
way to do it
what else can we talk about about hiring
we have a hacker rank challenge and we
have a we have the programming challenge
uh
comma ai uh speed prediction challenge
it's still actually a surprisingly good
challenge
um it's just a video
and the question is can you
from the video
uh figure out how the car is driving
how fast it's going it's tough house
it's going wow
it looks so weird with the old view
before hdr
but yeah just output the speed
uh if you're the type of person who
chooses where to work based on free
drinks and good food and i don't know
man
i don't know
um there's no name for zuke's is not a
public company
there's no name for the stock of zooks
this is cool
yo let's look at this one but in ml
transform land
i think uh no no it's not gonna know
i don't know which one that was no
never mind can't find that one again
it would have been cool to look at that
one in ml transform land though we could
look at that same we could look at that
same route but instead of looking at it
through the eyes of a camera you can
look it through the eyes of the model
uh yeah float why you think i want an
integer you think you think how
it's got to be a little more precise
than that don't you think
um modafinil is a schedule for
controlled substance
uh adrenal fill is not though
adrenal is probably still true uh is
that 3d model a custom library what 3d
model
but yeah i don't know guys i'm i'm
bearish on the streams
uh that's why i haven't been streaming
it a bit i'm bearish on the stream
uh being useful for for hiring uh
where's the hacker rank email in email
in a resume
uh the hacker and cost us like a dollar
so i think we ask you a few pre-screen
questions first so you feel worth a
dollar
most people worth a dollar um
yeah i'm bearish i'm bearish on the
utility of these streams
maybe that was just an error of comment
yeah that's over we're a real company
now we got
we got executives we got three divisions
we got profit
you know and i'm still the same guy hey
you know like gonna people don't change
right
um yeah hire some recruiters
put people to a process get some
bureaucracy up in here what do you all
think
um can you not click in the simulator
that sounds like your bugs are gonna fix
them
um yeah i know you like hearing from me
but the question is like
ask not what these streams can do for
you but what these streams can do for me
stream's important for selling products
i don't need to sell more products we're
profitable
we're making cash making cash boys
here take a look open up our shopify let
me
just look it over a little bit make sure
everything on the screen's okay
we don't like we don't like leaking
information about our customers
but as long as it's fully anonymized
data
uh it's all good
yeah buddy look at that money
look at that money look at money
um yeah so that's that's enough to run
the company uh
enough to yeah we're still selling phone
meetings thousand bucks
comey dot ai services uh you can buy a
meeting
uh wonder if investors don't vest until
they raise again so the investors own
equity in this company
um and it's preferred share so they're
totally welcome to sell it at any time
i think right now it'd be pretty easy if
they wanted to turn a profit to sell it
to somebody else
so welcome to deal
um yeah
if you're applying for a job here uh
think about which division
you'd like to apply for so we have three
divisions and we have a different
interview process
for each of the divisions we have the
open pilot division
uh the research division and the
operations division
um
why don't you open a small crowd funding
for a small portion of your equity but i
don't need money
why do i need money
ah
why do you live in the bear a dying
place
why don't you make cryptocurrencies
you're why i don't do streams man you're
why i don't do streams
we do hire interns uh the bar is almost
higher for interns
not similar to the bar similar if you're
really good you'll hire an internship
um here's kind of here's kind of like
how i think about it right
you got all the comm employees you can
put them in a
ranked list and then you have the mean
of that list right
we want to hire new people that bring up
the mean that's how you make sure
companies continually improve
am i looking for marketing why would i
do marketing i don't need more sales i
need more engineers to solve
self-driving cars
remember the mission of the company is
to solve self-driving cars
while delivering shippable
intermediaries right so what do we need
to solve self-driving cars well that
list there we really need someone
we really need someone to build out um
navigation i mean navigation is going to
be a big thing for the next year
we have a whole backend mapping effort
we need to hire people for
um well so do more engineers solve the
problem
more engineers are only good if you have
different things that need doing right
if if you know you know the saying right
um three women can't have a baby
uh you know if one woman if one woman
can have a baby in nine months three
women can have a baby in three months
um so i mean this is true if you're
having one baby but three women can have
three babies in nine months right
whereas one woman would take 27
actually probably not even you gotta
wait a little bit um
but see that's i mean that's what i mean
if you can if you can break it up into
different
uh like tasks
that need doing in order underneath the
big umbrella task of solving
self-driving cars
then having more software engineers
definitely helps right um another way to
think about this is amdahl's law
right like problems are parallelizable
to an extent
i think this is a classic it's unlike
ethical man ones and stuff
uh simulations are good for testing not
good for training
uh simulations do succeed if you train
the simulation i say this stuff all the
time too
so i write it all up write it all up the
real solution to self-driving
should i pull a sebastian throne and
start a udacity course for self-driving
right like sebastian throne's like [ __ ]
man that's gonna take another 10 years
to solve
i'm out i'll just train the people who
did it right
what do i think about maple area getting
bought by facebook well that's the end
of mapillary right who bought who bought
open
open street cam that was bought by some
company too it's sad you know these
things just go to die
ah
where does semi-trucks fall for me what
about semi-trucks
but yeah um the the whole point of the
company uh is the mission
so think about how i mean you can see
kind of what our breakdown is i'm pretty
open about how we do it
um we're trying to be the alphago of
self-driving the thing about alphago is
entering the self-driving car market now
all right
what's up driving car market
what self-driving car market are they
entering
there's no market
we're like the biggest market
no there's no there's no where is this
where is this market what are you what
are you buying right i guess i don't
know tammy tesla's making a lot more off
those off those full self-driving
yep but zoox isn't in a market zoox is a
research lab
you want to tap into our sales buy
coming to shop.com
um
i don't care about average i don't care
about hours
uh what is the average skill level i
mean look at the code right
i think it's quite high yeah it would
boost my revenue
yes but i don't need more revenue i need
i need
more talented software engineers right
like i didn't come here and win you know
i don't know is winning is winning just
out of out of out of phase in the world
right i want to have a job at google
where i do nothing with my life
and i tweak rest end points to make sure
we have accessibility
for cripples in czechoslovakia right
like that's that's that's
really um
that's what it comes down to that's what
these that's what these these you do
nothing at these companies
uh i don't know but yeah like like why
is
why is the software engineering talent
there software engineering talent also
goes to finance
you pay you're playing a scam game right
like you're playing a game with
you take you take the money and and uh
oh look i'm making all this money it's
all fake right
um
more exposure equals more engineers well
so i was hoping that
i was hoping that this year it seems to
not be that true
uh do you need to know about slam before
no
uh i didn't know about slam four years
ago i totally would hire myself right i
don't i'm not i'm not gonna ask you if
you know slam
uh in any in any uh in any interview
um where did most current engineers come
from
regions reach out i also do it right
like you just
you know it's the top one percent of the
people who apply and i'm like
okay half the people uh uh half the
people who we want
except the offer and yeah that's where
they come from right
um what's the first question i ask
uh what's the derivative
of x squared
not all engineers want to be an engineer
well don't be an engineer
do what you want amazon paid 1.2 billion
what do i think zuk's is actually worth
what's hard thing to value
um if you're thinking about future
returns of zuke's business model it's
worth negative money
if you're thinking about repurposing
this technology for making your
deliveries 20
faster then to be honest it might
actually be worth 1.2 billion to amazon
it might be worth more
right if you could figure out how to get
all amazon if you could do amazon
deliveries 20
more efficient that's easily worth the
money so i don't know if zuk's
technology can be uh
repurposed for that i don't like ross
um i think it's build libraries not
frameworks
i think ross is a framework and not a
library
we get a lot of the same stuff we now
have a
library called serial um commodore
cereal
sorry no github it's a github cereal
um and it does most of what ross does we
use cap and proto
for the binary packing format we used to
use zmq for message passing
but zmq puts the bike to the kernel
which is slow
so now we uh our head of open pilot
wrote a custom one that uses uh ring
buffers and shared memory
ah just a lot nicer
mr everything master
time out um
i need solve leak code how to keep the
model so small they're growing they're
getting big they're getting big we got
it we gotta we gotta change it
right now the models are being stored on
disk as float32
but they're only being used the weights
only be used by the gpus flow 16
so we can uh we can change that
uh
i don't know what elite code 500 problem
is
yeah the spammers are yeah
um yeah yeah i don't know
maybe it is the format of these streams
right i'm gonna do it
on twitch i did it a lot to just kind of
blow off steam and
kind of [ __ ] talk um but maybe that
doesn't attract the best sort of
audience
uh so i'll have to do a bit of a bit of
reflection
on how to get the right sort of people
and maybe the right sort of people are
out there and they're watching this
they're just not commenting
or they think they click around on it
they read the comments
uh when do i think kama will reach level
three
three years um that was kind of the
that's kind of the consensus of the
off-site level five is still too far
away to think about
um we were all pretty convinced that
it's more than five years away
but level three uh can be reached
significantly sooner
it's an achievable goal and it's what
we're pushing towards we need to get our
models to be so reliable in fact
when you're in level three level two has
a completely different safety paradigm
from level three
level two we don't trust the models we
have lots of stuff after
the models to prevent like high torques
on the steering wheel for example
right and this is good in the level two
system because we expect if a high
torque is required the user does it but
at level three where you can't rely on
the user or at least can't rely on the
user quickly
um that stuff becomes a lot less
relevant
so in three years world comma b well
you're a spammer so you don't get an
answer i was going to give you an answer
but you spammed
so now you get a timeout and no answer
uh yes
we're not working remotely we never
worked remotely
you know i'm 30 years old right
a lot of people here pretty young a lot
of people younger than me
the periscope era was awesome
it's for a different thing right like
we're not here to do we're not here to
i'm not here to promote the product
um i'm here to promote the company i'm
here to promote
put it this way you show me you show me
that uh you're a great engineer you show
me your great engineer and you're
skeptical
that com is gonna win and you're
skeptical that we're gonna win
self-driving cars do my programming
challenge do a programming challenge do
the hacker rank get a perfect score it's
easy
and then i'll do i'll do a phone call
with you with a 30-minute phone call
with you
and if at the end of the 30 minute phone
call i haven't convinced you i mean i'm
sure i will
i'm it's if you truly think about this
space
for your preconceptions and you look at
what's going to be required to solve
this problem
you're and you're versed in you know
the direction ml's been going the
direction the legacy self-driving car
companies have been going
the direction tesla's been going uh i'm
sure
after a 30-minute phone call uh i'll
convince you
redundancy is something to think about
after the software is good enough uh
most of the problems now are not caused
by
hardware failures but by software
failures i just have to be people within
the us
no we're happy to get you here we're
happy to look
if you're super talented we'll make it
work we'll figure out how to
not remote not remote i'm not going to
go that far but um
perhaps we'll have an office outside the
u.s
if visa things uh become an issue or if
we can sponsor your visa
we're happy to do it um honestly why you
should work at comma if google pays 3x
well so two things about that
one yeah sure google's salaries are
google salaries are 2x higher um but
your google equity is not going to 10x
right your google equity is there's no
10x growth for google
um there is very easily 10x growth for
comma so the upside could potentially be
much larger
working here instead of google um so
from a straight monetary perspective
you can make arguments for comma above
google um
but if you're into the straight monetary
arguments
you know it's boring uh the second
reason is what are you gonna do at
google
right do you think you're gonna build
something revolutionary or do you think
you're gonna look into a google docs bug
on ie6
and have to go through three stages of
code review and
you know uh sit through sit through
three meetings every day and
if that's what you want to do with your
life and that's what it's worth to get
well i'm getting double the money in the
bank right now
well you know i started as a risk right
um
but you know if you're talented with the
amount of equity you get
uh you stand to make a lot more money
here than you do google
um if you're not interested in software
development please go our google
uh you'd have an impact but honestly you
will make more money probably too
if if we succeed if comma actually gets
to level three within three years
you'll you'll you'll make more money
here at google
do i have any advice for early age stage
startups shut down while you still can
give the money back to your vcs tell
them sorry about the 30
haircut and be like i'm out bro
um what if google buys comma google's
not buying comma
i'm not selling the google put install
to google
two billion two billion i'll sell it to
google
uh and then i'll take the money and
start apostrophe
that's an hour long stream i'll go back
to work in a little bit it's almost
lunch time
uh product design mackies not really i'm
pretty much can you code
uh let's hear from someone in the
background they got things i'm not gonna
distract them it's bad enough they don't
distract yeah i'll start apostrophe
right
uh we use the um
i don't know i i know there's the
movement oh you gotta use pie torch
i think cross is nice
google may take that offer yeah google
takes that offer yeah and i'll go start
apostrophe with the money after i you
know get rid of my handcuffs after a
year right
2 billion 2 billion and you know what
you want to talk about i'm not just
going to talk with you you got to wire 2
million
first 2 million to come to the come to
the table how many hours do i work per
week 100 bro 100
how many hours am i awake it's more than
100 that's right
always working work is life
what is a posture if you do well the
same thing's comma
are we hiring front end devs um
it depends yeah maybe uh if you think
you can qualify as full stack
uh we'll hire you if you're full stack
with more emphasis on the front end
i will hire you if you're good with ui
stuff uh we'll hire you
so yeah if you're if you're uh
react javascript uh sure
um how good is zoox compared to comma
it's totally different
i don't care full stack does not require
any ml you won't be touching any of the
ml stuff
um are you looking for graduates or
senior experience levels i don't care
um we have we have an intern here he's
20
it's genius you know uh and if there
were if there were
five more people uh like him i'd i'd uh
i'd give them all full-time jobs
what type of job security can you offer
look here's the thing about that
question
you actually have quite decent job
security but if you're the kind of
person who's interested in job security
you completely you'd never you'd never
work here you'd never you'd never like
like we're trying to do something new
right we're not trying to maintain
google docs for ie6 here
um with respect to like to ask the
question
seriously all right this is saying look
if your program doesn't finish in one
second it won't finish in two if your
program doesn't finish in two seconds it
won't finish in four four
eight eight sixteen so on and so forth
comma's been around for five years
uh we're a profitable company we've
raised 8.1 million dollars which is
laughable
uh compared to what we have um so
yeah i mean the company's not going
anywhere uh so with respect to job
security like that if you're worried
about the company disappearing i
wouldn't worry about that if you're
worried about getting fired that's a
personal thing between
you and your skills um
you know i mean there's a job security
question like is comma shutting down
next week
am i going to announce tomorrow sorry
guys we couldn't raise any money you're
all bought by amazon no
of course not all right that's an hour
thank you for joining uh coming i slash
jobs uh you want to win three years to
level three
uh be a part of the winning team
get rich change the world that's right
see you later